we got mercedes uh calling us mercedes
how are you
i'm good thank you chris ah focus to not
finish how can we help you today
um hi anthony as well um just a question
to clarify about baby step number four
um i know it's 15 of gross income
my husband and i have a household income
where
marginal tax rate is 53.5
does that still apply 15 growth
or would you do something different in
that case okay well no the 15
is still going to stay the same uh
what's you all's household income
um net after tax sure up
about 700. okay all right and
let me ask you do you all have any debt
right now
yeah okay so your home is paid for and
everything
uh the home is not paid for no we do
have a mortgage okay well that'd be debt
so what how much do you owe on the home
yes
um 1.5 okay all right
so uh what what line of work are you all
in
uh my husband is an investment advisor
okay
all right and so looking at this yeah
the income side uh
welcome to texas uh but but you guys are
in canada
i'm correct right yeah okay
so even in looking at that yeah you're
gonna get in that habit of the 15
of their household income from an
investing standpoint
your husband being an investment advisor
he knows you know there are options and
things that you guys can do
obviously pre-tax but post-tax you guys
have a little bit different
investment system up there with rrsps
but you still have the opportunity to be
able to save and invest
but also you guys would look at
opportunities to really throw
i mean get hyper vigilant and gazelle
intense
at chopping down that mortgage yes
and that's what we've been doing like
we're paying it unfortunately i found
you guys
after we bought the place so we're not
on a 15.
but we're paying it as though it is a
15. okay well and mercedes you know how
often people continue to do that
consistently rarely okay
no i'm serious everybody's got
intentions but i thought i heard
something over there you guys have kids
i just want you yeah how old is the baby
uh
almost a year and a half okay see i knew
i heard that sound i got that paternal
instinct
uh but you guys be in focus i would i
would tell you i advise you i'd go
refinance to a 15-year fix
you guys have the income you can do it
uh you're gonna see it then
and it's gonna be five six seven hundred
dollars more but
just getting in that habit refinancing
it down to a 15 is gonna lock you
into that so now it's not a matter of if
you feel like it or not
uh you guys are gonna have to avoid
what's called income stupid
meaning because you do have a higher
level of income you can tend to do
stupid on a larger scale
can i get an amena amen brother and so
you got to be careful with that
so you guys locking in on a 15 being
intentional and also ao with that little
one they can start saving for college
absolutely man i would definitely start
looking to at 529 if they're already not
doing it because it sounds like they're
they're doing the right things
you know they're asking the right
questions so i would definitely open up
a 529
and start stacking away some money for
college yeah they're in canada so you'd
have to look and see what's the
equivalent up there
of you all being able to put money away
but then at the same time being
intentional and i mean
attacking this mortgage at your income
level this house can be paid off in two
to three years tops
without you all sacrificing lifestyle
mercedes so sit down talk to your
husband
uh he'll either see that picture or he
may be too wise to see it right now
because a lot of people ao try to
convince themselves because there are
people out there that don't know how to
count
that having a mortgage is a good thing
so you can write off the interest
you've got to be kidding me you know i
people when i hear nerds say that i want
to grab them by their pocket protector
and just shake them
but i can't do that because that's
assault but i want people to understand
you know you pay it off you remove the
risk of the mortgage in your life
you're getting rid of risk you're
freeing it up and now you can donate
money to charities or causes you believe
in and use that as the tax write-off man
you teaching good today are you okay
hogan i'm i'm fired up today
what's in this drink leave it alone
there's caffeine in there baby i'm
rolling